so this is a new class I haven't taught
before in which you guys bring your own
game and we go over them I love the idea
of this class because it's important to
be able to see what types of mistakes
people are making we're slightly better
than you or slightly weaker than you
rather than seeing what types of
mistakes the elite grandmasters are
making because obviously there's a lot
of differences there especially when you
look at classical time control games so
the first game I'm gonna look at which
who submitted the English game and
what's your name Gabriel so we're gonna
look at a Gabriel's English game and you
were playing white or black in this game
so you were playing white so the English
is your opening my dad actually always
used to play doing that she's a feat a
master and Greg and I kind of went in
the absolute opposite direction and
played before and English is always one
of the hardest openings to play against
for me and some of you guys might have
the same paper problems the problem
playing against the English when you're
black is if you play an opening where
you can get into some move order tracks
and a lot of the most popular defenses
against Queen Pond don't really work
that well against the English one that
one example is the ground foul if you if
you like to play the groom float and
your opponent plays the English it's
kind of annoying because you can't
really play it it's you can play for
defy but it's kind of a slightly
different opening where White has more
options they can they can throw in a
little bit of a queen a four-track and
you're not really contesting the center
in the exact same way so that is why it
doesn't quite work to play the groom
code and see English you can play a
quasi room foul but it's not exactly the
groom palette and then another even more
well another very popular opening the
nimzo-indian you also can't really play
against the groom against the English
because in this position white can play
instead of d4 transpose inning to the
nihms oh they can play E for instead is
that what you do
but sometimes you do this thing yeah I
think this is kind of dangerous yeah so
in any case one of the things I like
about c4 is that when you're playing
especially at the non-professional level
it can confuse your opponents because
obviously you're spending most of your
time against before because that's what
you're getting most of the time and then
you're spending a second most time
definitely on d4 and even if you see d4
almost as often as e4 you're still
probably spending slightly more time on
e4 because it's sharper right so if you
had to choose between studying your
Sicilian or your double King bond versus
your defense against d4 you might choose
the the e4 opening just because you
don't want to get crushed so I think
it's a good choice for people who like
positional chests starting out no this
is one of the openings where it really
doesn't matter luckily for your opponent
if you play a Slav then it's fine
to play the slob against the English so
you're in luck in that case and you who
here has no transpositional difficulties
against c4 because they play something
like the slob or the Queen's Gambit
decline is also totally legit I'm sorry
well if you play the care out Kahn the
problem is your opponent might not play
you for here like if they play e4 you're
gonna transpose into some kind of pan
off but if they play d4 then you really
have to play the slob so if you play the
Carroll Khan and the slob and you're all
set but if you only play the slob and
you don't play the Carroll you might
have to study some other lines
specifically tailored for the English
like of course the classical ePHI all
right obviously you can just play that
but the only annoying thing with playing
c-45 is that if your opponent plays
Knight f3 on the first move you have to
learn a little e different opening for
that C because Knight f3 is this allows
e5 but next move they might play c4
anyway so it's really an irritation
because now you can just play Knight c6
and play e5 next because then they could
play E for and like do you play this
maybe maybe not probably not so I mean
if you play e5 here are you transposed
to a mainline
they can also play d4 here and you
probably don't play that so it's a it's
tricky that when you're playing and c4
you also have to have something for
Knight f3 and they both have to work so
that's that's one of the biggest
challenges so I love the movie 5 and I
would play it except that it would be
like learning a whole new thing and then
if my opponent saw that I didn't play
like d5 against Knight of 3 they could
just say oh I'll just play Knight of 3
against her and try to get the same
types of lines to avoid hurry 5 does
that make sense so it can be really
irritating so instead though your
opponent just played for this and now
you can you continue to just play
something which has no theory in it
really not I mean I don't know the
theory I'm sure obviously there's a
little bit of theory in every opening
but I'm not I'm not really aware of this
so you just decide to fee encounter your
Queen's Bishop and really play chess and
get out of luck as they say and the
thing about this type of opening is that
this double thiink at all actually I
think a lot of great Georgian players
Georgia the country not the state has
played this kind of thing and now if he
tries to hop in and attack f2 you can
just simply play III or something like
that or even play something on and
probably three all right yeah and that
doesn't seem to lead to much I'm gonna
create some holes but the time waste
it's not really worth it for him so he
just instead he played 95 ok that's kind
of an interest name of he's just trying
to get his Bishop out I suppose maybe I
considered taking on c4 at some moment
as well well if d4 in this position I
guess the problem is you're cutting off
your own Bishop here but it's still did
you consider d4 yeah
and also he just has this nice where
it's not terrible but it doesn't look
very harmonious for white either it just
feels like this bishop feels a little
strange and we really need to get
castles so instead you just play d3 that
seems good so now you clean 92 instead
of Bishop g2 I guess next move you're
gonna play Bishop g2 so now you play
Bishop g2 and I like your position here
what did you think so what have you
played 95 right away here because now
you're actually attacking this Knight
and you're attacking this Bishop well
yes so 95 my idea is I want to take a
bishop off the positions opening up a
little bit so I like the two bishops so
what does he do here he obviously has to
either take on f3 or just move this guy
immediately I'm not sure what's best
there's also some potential tactical
things going on here I don't think they
quite work though well I was trying to
take on c6 but that doesn't work because
you can still go drop back with a knight
for the moment with white just by age 3
and then just play Bishop a5
yeah well sure you could do that too but
I was I was just uh I'm not sure that
you want to you could just take the
bishop immediately if you want awesome
you just go here like right now and then
after this just kind of developed
normally Bishop g2 or something like
that it seems like a kind of nice oh
yeah nice edge for white because also
this night is really awkwardly placed on
e6 probably not the best choice I was
just like a random choice I made I think
97 makes a lot more sense seems more
harmonious right but still definitely
some advantage the white here yeah yeah
yeah and you can still maybe consider
expanding sometime at some point with b4
and b5 you know once you get your Bishop
to g2 just kind of reconfigure things a
little bit and try to go for that
minority attack where you're pushing the
B and the a pawns forward definitely
like ye yeah whenever there's an
unprotected piece I always look I always
kind of like put my alert bells up
they say loose pieces drop off that's a
cheesy little tactic Manama that a
famous book by a motwani coined it some
time ago and yeah there's just sometimes
it's positional though right it's not
leader actually winning material with 95
but that's still being aware of those
loose pieces often create some taxable
opportunities and I mean I would look at
I would look at other moves too you can
also look at 93 seems kind of similar
though right except now you're allowing
which takes up three hurting your pawn
structure so that would be bad actually
so 95 seems better and then there's no
moves that actually win material right I
don't really see anything better
yeah all right after II yeah that's a
that's a good question but first of all
if you wanted to you can take with this
and then this is protected by the Bishop
III but then I'm first of all isn't no
longer and take but even if it wasn't
even if for some reason I took with this
pawn which know if I would do that but
even so after 93 Bishop takes f3 is also
an in-between move because it hits the
bishop on h1 so even in this line this
would be kind of bad for right actually
because then after pawn takes we move
the knight and this structure is exactly
the opposite of the structure we had
earlier where we was kind of pristine
right so instead you just played Bishop
g2 then you play h6 well now you still
have the opportunity to play an 85 right
so this still works and it's actually
getting better all the time because in
this I hope I didn't overwrite the game
so I'd be very mad um I think intro Z or
something works but after Knight d7 now
every little thing changes a little bit
and I feel like things are getting even
better because now like you've wasted to
move with this sometimes have you been
trying to like play Bishop Age 3 I don't
think it does much just castle and
you're just really behind in development
so instead you're just castled and then
oh oh wait wait wait wait yeah it does
change something I knew or something
bigger than that what about maybe it's
maybe it's not that big of a deal but
I'm looking at night III now and now you
can't actually move the night
well you might still be able to but it's
starting to get really messy whether
it's something like this works you can
still take with a knight and I guess
your card I was just looking at weird
stuff like Bishop takes f3 and Bishop
takes d7 just trying to desperado snag
one pawn but it seems like black and
on there anyway still a good line but
nothing like winning or anything like
that so castles is what you did and now
he played you six finally protecting
that night and then you went with the
other night to e5 I guess you were kind
of feeling this night here okay and then
you play Bishop f5 all right so there's
like some sacrificial possibilities here
I'm sure you're starting to analyze what
happens after Knight takes c6 right but
what do you guys think of it obviously
you always have to look at this kind of
stuff because you're getting you're
getting two pawns and a rock for a
knight and a bishop you have to put one
of these nights here which one probably
this one and now what's the prognosis
here
what do you guys think how many people
think this is a bad idea for right how
many people thank God it's a good idea
for a yeah I mean it you I mean I think
you've got the right idea here I'll say
that if it's all we have here is it a
honey ant it's not a good idea for white
because even though like materially we
got two ponds we can away our beautiful
Bishop and now you've actually got some
counter playing the light squares rather
than before when we were dominating
light squares and yet I would still look
at this so this variation I just don't
like and it's not a matter of
calculation anymore it's okay our
portents gonna play Bishop e7 and Castle
like there's really nothing more to
calculate it's it's all a matter of feel
you've got seven pawns verse five pawns
so that's technically a two-point
advantage plus the exchange is another
two points but it's it's I'd still
prefer I don't even think in these terms
of points really so it's like kind of
hard to add it all up but I just like I
just look at this Queen and diagonal and
I just really miss my old friend I miss
my friend a lot that Bishop on g2 that's
that's why we play the English right I
mean I don't play the English but I play
the dragon so I feel your pain if you
played this variation but I would still
look at this because it's one of those
things or kings still in the center I
want to look at this because what if
there's a tactic right and then there's
almost a tactic but I don't see anything
that really drives a knife in like I'm
looking at it all these forcing lines
efore first of all you have Bishop h3
which is kind of a problem but even if
you go back if I've just doesn't really
seem to lead to that much because I
don't have any way to put more pressure
in this right and your other idea Bishop
takes up six the problem is how you've
given up your other powerful Bishop
and although if I take with a queen
that's bad news what if I just take with
a pawn sure it's not ideal for the
castle position but if you're giving up
all your minor pieces then my King
safety is not going to be as paramount
anyway right so yeah I think that I
would pass but always look because you
never know what if your opponent does
something I ain't just just for the sake
of argument like it's always it's never
really a massive waste to look in a line
like that because what if your opponent
what if you play just something show
like this and then your opponent does
like that like it looks like a terrible
move but just for the sake of argument
now suddenly maybe things have changed a
little bit because now they can't move
with this Knight because of that and if
they move with this now we do have this
again now right because after a queen
takes bishop takes a a we're actually
winning material and maybe we're winning
even more material if we just take on d7
well if we take on d7 immediately you're
your king has to take which doesn't look
fun but what which one's better it's
like well something is good here who
that's for sure
so that's kind of an artificial example
because g5 is a terrible move but that
kind of thing happens all the time
you check out a technical variation it
doesn't work three moves later you saved
yourself a ton of work because the same
tactic arises but now there's a little
thing your opponent did that makes it
winning right so never think of time
spent analyzing tactics as a total waste
of time as long as you don't actually
get into trouble on the clock it could
come in handy later okay yeah I like
making terrible moves to make arguments
okay before instead and then after
Knight d7 you just took and now you
played a3 okay so you've got that idea
where you want to go for the minority
attack okay I approve of that your
opponent played Brooks he ain't
Claybrook c1 Queens g5 and he's having
trouble developing because the g7 pawn
was in dake so now by playing Queen g5
he's finally ready to develop his
bischmann fa8 and just still looks
really yeah that's a good question
that's just similar to what we were just
looking at where you're getting a pond
and a but here you're giving up the
knight and the bishop for the exchange
but here also note that your work on
anyone's in hanging at the end of the
variation and you're only getting one
bond so after King f8 Knight CA I think
this doesn't look like it's gonna go
well for you I mean I honestly I'm I'm
so I'm so partial to these bishops I I
hesitate to even take this but I think
it's probably good and then after rook
a1 queen c8 and I'm up I'm up a piece
right for a pawn just not nearly enough
compensation yeah I tell you this my
dragon though even though it's the best
move it seems I still it's hard for me
to even an analysis take go Bishop takes
a one there because the bishop is just
such a spectacular defender and attacker
right but still works are good yes yeah
but we're just getting so simplified
that even though it feels like it feels
painful it is probably better to take
the rooks cuz the more you get
simplified the more the rooks shine and
that's why you see a lot of exchange
sacrifices and the opening in the middle
game because in the middle game and
attacks in the king minor pieces knights
and bishops are just as strong as rocks
but in the endgame
it's like there's no contest the rooks
are the Brooks just crushed so you see a
lot of those sacrifices earlier anyway
very interesting good tactical I that
you're looking for those loose pieces
but it's not working and then instead
working although we're seeing on
honestly I when you when you said
something besides Brooks t1 I also
jumped out at me because blacks still
three moves from castling work c1 seems
really slow to me
I kind of want to break things open
somehow I'm more of an e4 player so it
doesn't come as naturally to me but in
general like the whole I'm looking for
ways to break open the position here
even a three pains me a bit but I guess
you kind of want to defend before not
that you've been really new to because
g7 is intake but I'm just like thinking
what if we just start going for it here
like efore and like try to play f4 also
and you just you're having trouble
defending like you can't move this
bishop because of this pawn you see
great d4 players go for these types of
attacks a lot and since I'm more me for
player I don't do it as much but I love
the fact that II four players think
they're the aggressive ones but then d4
player they're actually sometimes the
ones that get these awesome attacks
because they have usually more Center
pawns to work with right I don't know
this looks actually really good for
white to me
like bushes
being aggressive like these are things
you know they don't occur to me or I
guess because they're only caution
fairly consciously or something
well that's an interesting point because
what you're saying is that you don't you
don't like consider these moves as much
because you don't want to weaken
yourself and also there's something to
be said for the fact that the English
opening usually you're playing on the
queenside but what I tell a lot of my
students is that this is one of the
reasons why it's great to look at games
of your peers or slightly stronger
players and not only the great 2700 s
because when you look at the games of
the greats they play the opening so well
that usually if you're playing English
you do play on the queenside because
your opponent is playing logically your
opponent in this game did not play as
well his development is very poor and
when your opponent doesn't play as well
that's when you deviate from a the
theory and not just the theory but even
the general ideas in the opening you
know like you're able to expand from the
theory because your opponent played
poorly and play more aggressively it's
very logical right they make mistakes so
you get to play more aggressively that's
all there is to it and here I I don't
like blacks position at all I think this
actually really strong looking at actor
me even though I feel your pain about
this pawn becoming weak I just I don't
see how they can develop I mean with her
play work t8 I guess they have to try to
play like f-16 you just took off all
right it's black smooth I mean I have to
figure out a way to develop and
dependent defend this pawn that's why
you're wanting to end up playing Queen
g5 so the nice thing is that this
protects that Eve what you think the
problem is that it loses a pawn all
right yeah so we can actually play at
five next maybe and try to like really
crack things open with the King in them
at all it's logical you want to open up
the position when your opponent's king
is in the center and I like the person
who mentioned Bishop takes g7 you even
though it's not good because I think
what it is is there's this feeling if
you're that that the position is where
she wants to slow for this position you
know like you get this gut feeling their
King is in the center they've got four
moves to do castle you got to develop
your gut where you say no way am i
playing a slow move here at least I'm
going
look for the aggressive moves all right
so we're Casey Wan Queen g5 Queen g5
seems kind of weird
like I understand this point that he's
trying to defend g7 but again I'm not
sure about this Queen maneuver here that
seems a little awkward again I would
think about a move like f4 you should
look at games lip from some really good
D for players like they don't have to be
like the best in the world but like even
like some people who come to the club
like you've got been fine gold in Yasir
Sarah Juan and Irina crash look at some
of their attacking games these guys are
not just winning every game playing work
B 1 and B 5 before they're also
checkmating their opponents and it's
hard to play against a strong d4 player
who knows how this is when a d4 player
gets excited or c4 player when they're
able to like start just like pushing
their center forward like that but yeah
like if you put it up for what do they
can do here the queen is like in
trapping territory like if they play
like this or something I feel like
they're gonna get trapped maybe not
immediately but it feels dangerous I
guess they always have g6
yeah Bishop i3 Queen g6 and then you're
gonna trap my bishop here maybe I'm
trying to maybe do this one first move
order and then and then it like if they
go here and trying to self self mate
your Queen here it looks like we're
close to trapping territory now 93 now
you're getting really low on squares
we're gonna trap you one way or the
other I'm so close so close yet so far
right because now you've got b5 again
hi we need to like block and then drop
the Queen it's a really cool position
maybe something like f5 takes and Bishop
f3 you know then you got when you're
well regardless this position looks
absolutely terrible for black so one way
or the other the game will be one f4
queen g4 just looks awful
Queen g6 I mean doesn't really matter
what you do we're gonna start expanding
right like if you play queen g6 we'll
play E for er and it looks like it looks
like in this position your Bishop
actually is getting draft right and yeah
you can get a little bit of compensation
but it's not gonna be sufficient so yeah
I think you need to go for something
like that
Queen c3 instead h5 alright well I guess
that helps them a bit because now if you
play F for something he can at least go
to h6 Queen d4 yeah these queen
maneuvers are not really helping that
much here what's that yeah okay he's
gonna win the fun there huh and then you
finally play d4 here
will you plead you for now okay still
probably good I still think this
position should be good for you it's
just illogical like that his position
should be good because he's got so
little development and he's still not
Castle so I don't believe in his
position here well this is kind of cool
for those of you who are studying
tactics trainer those why do
I'm better
although Bishop f3 might be really good
too but hey there's just a immediate
yeah Queen taste e7 winning a piece
right so always looking at that kind of
tactical idea it's those are the types
of things that are if you look at
tactics book they come up all the time
so if you practice that you will get
better at seeing them well the thing is
the good players what they do is they
actually first of all the Queen is loose
which helps make it more possible but
then literally strong players do have
these computerize as we call them in
this great book forcing moves where they
talk about how strong players play
better tactically computerized means
that on some level you look at every
capture most of them it's like a
millisecond you're not really looking at
it you're not giving it your full
attention because it's obviously bad
right like I'm not really looking at
Queen takes JSON map but most most
captures you're giving it that second of
respect Queen a7 Queen d7 and that's how
you find the great sacrifices so it's
much more prosaic than oh they see it
right away no they actually are looking
at everything yeah there was a famous
chess player who said like that he
looked at first when he sees a chess
position first he looks at all the Queen
sacrifices then all the rook sacrifices
then all the bishop sacrifices then all
the normal moves so he actually goes
through all of them but that process
might take us a total of 30 seconds but
he still does it you know 30 seconds
because some of them might just be so
obviously wrong right okay so Queen d7
would have been good but this position
is theoretical anyway but I was I was
talking about how f4 is a nice move
again stormed partial to f4 he probably
has to go to h5 or g6 and now of course
Queen d7 is not as good because after an
85 check the Queen's protected so it's
just a trade
and not clear that you want to trade one
of the biggest benchmarks for whether or
not you want to trade Queens is whether
or not your king or his king and safer
and here it seems that even though it's
not as clear as before because you your
point has gotten a little bit of headway
with the H pawn seems pretty clear that
blacks came in far graver danger right
yeah any case you did not play that oh
you do play you for you do not play that
for you put an 86 Jack yeah a 96 check
ID on I'm not sure if it's good or not I
have to give it a little bit more
individual attention but my first gut is
I don't love the fact that you're
solving a problem that he's had for a
while but you may have a good follow up
to it so I don't want to heat on it yet
because he can't Castle I mean you might
be able to in Queen e7 seems
insufficient because then he's going to
lose the g7 pawn in this position might
be decent to I mean it's not like it's
it's not certainly what like jumps to my
mind but yeah like just start taking
pawns doesn't look bad to me cuz you
guys know what TAC really the problem I
mean like yes sure he can take here and
I don't even I don't even think like
it's a problem to take with this pawn
like even maybe Meishan even if we give
him a bunch of moves like let's say you
squeeze first of all you can just take
care but then exactly right like even if
we don't take on d7 let's just say we
play a dummy move even worst-case
scenario we don't take there and Queen
h5 you just move your rook and this goes
to show the beautiful defensive powers
of this Bishop that actually this Queen
on h2 doesn't do a whole lot I mean you
really would need to get your official
money h3 to cause any headway and that
doesn't look like it's happening anytime
soon
now that being said obviously I still
probably prefer to avoid this but I like
it even if they get their queen to h2
it's still not a big issue and meanwhile
you're gonna be snapping off all their
pawns so yeah Queen i7n greedy but seems
also reasonable so I mean more than
reasonable like probably just also
wait it looks very very good so 96
instead and after Bishop takes d6 Queen
b6 takes on g3 take back with the F on
okay it's hard for me to imagine this
isn't still very good for you okay look
the 8th ok Queen f4 I am how might be
where things start to go awry a little
bit because still think your King is
safer than his so when you trade Queens
I'm not sure that's going to be good for
you yeah I like Queen c7 and you just
thought like eventually he I mean I mean
what's the problem here I like if he
castles yeah I think you're going to
start taking pawns off his position just
looks like this bishop still looks
absolutely terrible and his coordination
is woeful and you're gonna snap off one
more pond yeah the problem is you're
just your Queens actually very powerful
on d6 I think you're you're starting to
feel a little bit of heat because the
work is on the same file as the Queen
which in general is true that you need
to watch out but here it's actually kind
of irrelevant because I mean first of
all you can just move the Queen and even
if you didn't
and this knight doesn't have any good
discoveries so yeah we have for a lot of
times mistakes and chests are made
because we don't look at all the
captures or checks but another big place
where mistakes are made are in
evaluations of captures the reason for
that is when we evaluate a capture
sometimes we let our emotions and
general principles get in the way things
that we heard like two bishops are good
at a 10-game and like something it just
kind of gets in your head and you're you
know don't think fully objectively and
also captures and cheston's when the
stakes are high so therefore when
there's a Queen trade always slow down
and try to think with both brains in
that I want you to think calculating but
also try to really bring out your more
verbal strategic positional brain when
you're talking about a trade of queens
because that's what sometimes gets lost
well you start thinking like who's
Kenya's safer do I want to trade Queens
in this position do I have a better
chance to attack more than them because
those are not things that you can always
subscribe very quickly in a variation
like if you're as calculating your just
like looking five moves ahead you're not
necessarily thinking about all those
things and in a queen trade you really
got to look at all the longer-term
factors move orders is really massive
impact the boss so yeah I think that
this were the first time in the game I
still think you have an edge but it's
the first time where I don't think it's
like a massive edge um oh it's pretty
I still think you have an edge I'm
trying to think how big it is it's hard
to tell I think it depends on how much
counterplay they get against this pawn
on d3 but this works you for it looks
kind of weird but I guess you're a
threat named g7 so that's why you did it
you played f6 hmm black playing e5
instead it looks a little better yeah
and if you're if I'm white here
I feel if I'm white here I'm not sure
what I'm doing trying to think I want to
try to get things out here I feel like I
should be doing well as white but I'm
not totally sure how to proceed maybe a
four or something
yeah and plus the queen on d6 was pretty
strong like it could just go to c7 and
start pumping ponds off that was another
problem it wasn't just it was actually
it was actually partly that the Queen
was really strong so you don't want to
trade it I might go with this plan here
something like with a for another thing
that we might want to think about is is
trying to get d4 in at some point and
then just play d5 and then we're then
it's true just to try to really
highlight our bishops like say they play
a6 I don't know what they play here the
problem is their positions very passive
like Knight f6 or something maybe
yeah probably NATO six and now you can
certainly consider playing d5 here might
be good take and then Bishop f6 tano six
yeah we've transitioned a little bit
we've treated a lot but pawn looks
pretty weak I don't know though I would
like to I look like something maybe a
little bit clearer but that's that's
definitely something you can think of
that's like a worst case scenario that
you're gonna get like a slightly better
position where you trade off a bunch of
stuff and you're gonna be a little bit
on top maybe you can find something even
better but I still like the game for you
rook to you for f6 is what you did and
now here I'd still consider playing d4
because now there's some benefits
actually because if he plays if he tries
to play e5 you can just go d5 straight
away so instead you played work Heffron
it's your kind of shuffling around here
and he got a little bit coordinated as a
result now if they worked you forth
running something on f6
yes it's not that clear
oh you didn't see it okay but it's like
yeah yeah things were things kind of
improved for him a lot in this position
he's kind of coordinated his pieces and
now what looks like he finally he
managed to actually get a get a little
bit of a grip on that d3 pawn which
didn't really ever have to happen so
then you found this variation with
Bishop b5 and he sake had to sacrifice
in exchange but it didn't end up seeming
so bad did it because your yeah work t3
not a good blockade ER and your work on
g4 is like totally trapped and you can
still take on FX although now you can
maybe take on e4 yeah that's a bit of
annoyance that he can take on any for
although yeah in Ricky 60s Bishop f5
mess mess mess yeah right so you good
now for q4 want a sub sex
so now you're trying to get your work
out this way well we sure got your work
out somehow
I guess I would try to think now this is
this seems like an achievement to me so
I try to like play here and see see if I
can wiggle it around the other way
and but this pawn is always hanging huh
you don't want to lose that pawn but if
you moved your work over here and then I
guess you're concerned that's what he
did but the problem was okay so he did
centralize the king he played well he
played King f1 you mean King f2 well I
think the problem is he's gonna get
checked here and then this work is gonna
have a lot of play but you want to just
pull a king up through here yeah that's
probably better than the game let's see
Maisie for annoying rough placement cuz
now when I work now or 392 check and and
taking on e4 or just taking on a3
you're always looking for those pawns I
like it very good yeah I I don't like it
it's a good position because it's very
instructive actually that you want to
get your those frontal attacks with the
rook are often effective in the middle
game I in my commentary broadcast I
often call them Rovers for work up and
over
but in the end game a rover is usually
terrible actually because it keeps your
rook away from the files that you need
to control and this is a good
demonstration out of it that your book
is a really bad participant in the
action here so I guess uh what happens
no this didn't happen
how can you do that this is what
happened right well yeah I mean you're
just gonna lose for sure when you take
on d4 I guess but I don't see uh I
probably wouldn't I wouldn't take on d4
I'd make them work for it here but and
it's not gonna be easy
yeah I don't think you need to need to
do that yet but it's looking grim I'd
still just because I want to get that
work into the game but then you get to
take out any four which is such a keep
on it's a problem and 94 it with the
idea and ID to check it's coming so I
don't think you can save a pawn on e4 so
you kind of have to just give it away I
guess probably I would do this looks it
looks really grim but I still think you
have a better chance of fighting here
and then you do if you just give up the
bishop anyway pretty instructive game
I'm glad you submitted it because there
were a lot of traditional things that we
learned I think and an important concept
for those of you who play d4 or c4 that
that it's not just a queen side opening
that there are a lot of attacks that
generate from pushing those pawns
forward and a lot of d4 openings you see
our opponents trying to get f3 and at
the right moment so that they can play
e4 alright now this is not a view for
opening it's a see for opening but we
saw kind of similar principles so
playing 1 c4 is not an excuse not to
attack that's the key every opening you
know whether you play e4 d4 see for the
most aggressive or the most team opening
there's always going to be moments where
you have to execute the skill that comes
less naturally to you and the best
players are universal and are good at
both things attacking and chilling out
and doing nothing I feel like are kind
of opposite poles right chilling out and
doing what seems like nothing but
actually slightly improves your position
and it seems like that was what you're
good at which is usually the opposite
most amateur players when they get into
chess they come to it because they love
to attack so you kind of have a leg up
on people that you actually like that
aspect of the game
develop both sides